PAUL: You see, you've got
that look on your face,
because you know
you're winding me up.
JAKE: Yes, I do.
PAUL: Yeah.
Yeah, you are.
All your problems are gone.
JAKE: So what's your
problem, then, Paul?
PAUL: My problem with
this is the page load
time is this proxy for
all your performance
problems are sorted.
No, no, and again--
once again, no.
Right?
I've got two major
issues right now.
One is to get good page load
time, people defer everything
to DOM content loaded.
JAKE: Right.
PAUL: And they-- or
body load, or whatever.
And they create-- I like to
think of as a 9:00 AM rush hour
problem.
They all go, you know
what we should do?
We should make sure the roads
are all clear until 8:45,
and then everybody
should go on the roads.
JAKE: So what's the effect
of this that you're seeing?
It's that as you-- as the page
loads, it has a moment of jank?
PAUL: More than a
moment, actually.
It's like-- honestly, it can
be at least several seconds.
Because we know that when
people first hit a page,
the first thing they try and
do is tap, or scroll, some kind
of interaction.
And it's the very
time that we've all
chosen to do all our work.
JAKE: Yeah.
PAUL: And it drives me mad.
This is not-- you can
get a good first paint,
and then completely hose
the user's expectation
by doing this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And then the other
thing that bothers
me is this, kind of,
disregard for anything that
happens after the page load.
Like, I've got it on the screen.
It's now the browser's problem
if it doesn't scroll well,
if it doesn't
transition well, if it
doesn't stick to
finger when they're
interacting in some ways.
JAKE: Well, 50% of
the answer will be,
have you tried virtual DOM?
PAUL: So vDOM.
All right, fine.
I think vDOM is actually
a very clever idea.
Because I think
what it's doing is
it's making sure you don't
shoot yourself in the foot.
JAKE: This is the key to it.
I don't know.
When people say that to
me, it feels like-- I say,
oh, god, my train
journey takes quite long.
It's like 40 minutes.
And people say,
ah, have you tried
wearing better running shoes?
It's like, well, I'm still
going to be there on the train,
with those running shoes.
And so if things like React
that do the virtual DOM thing,
they are still going
to work with the DOM?
PAUL: Yeah.
JAKE: Like, if you
have 100 elements
to create on the page, that
will be slower with React.
PAUL: Yeah.
JAKE: Because React
is on the top.
PAUL: Yes.
And also, I've seen
timeline traces
where all the work was React.
That's not React's
fault, but it struck me
that the developer might be
thinking, well, essentially all
the work I do in React,
or all the work I
do with vDOM is free.
It's only the bit at the end
that I have to pay the cost on.
JAKE: But where things
like React really come
into their own is where
you can just sort of-- you
can create a whole load of new
objects to represent the DOM
and say, this is what
it should look like.
PAUL: Right.
JAKE: You can write your
code really naively,
and React will cater for that.
And rather than create a
whole set of corresponding DOM
elements, it will take
what's already there,
move that all around,
change the order,
and just create the
new stuff it needs.
And that's the sort of
practical performance benefit.
It's not the DOM that's slow.
It's kind of your use of it.
PAUL: I think-- exactly.
It's very much your use of it.
I think it's very nice
to have the headlines,
like, the DOM is slow.
Or always use CSS animations.
But, no.
Because it completely
misses the nuance.
JAKE: This is
something I've been
kind of exploring more and more
recently is that displaying
what looks like a
complete interface,
but it's not actually ready.
Is that OK?
Is that something you--
PAUL: Yeah.
Well, so long as the thing
that they want to interact with
will work.
JAKE: This is the problem
with what Apple recommend
with their-- because
they have only
a few dimensions of phones.
You can include essentially
screenshots of every device
as your initial render.
The problem with that is
that it won't be clickable.
So I think what they recommend
is just something that
has the colored bars and stuff?
PAUL: Yeah.
JAKE: I think we should be
doing more of that on the web.
But not with bitmaps, because
windows can be any size.
But with something with just
a very small blob of CSS,
a little bit of
HTML and Flexbox,
or whatever it is, just
to do your sort of basic--
PAUL: Bare bones.
Yeah.
I think that's absolutely fine.
Like, that has to be part of it.
Perceived performance is a huge
part of this whole discussion.
And I think as Service
Worker is more widely
used, as we get to this
kind of fast bootstrapping
offline-y world,
where people are
sort of tapping on things
from their home screen,
well, it's all
this bit afterwards
that actually is going to
shape user expectation.
That's the bit they're
going to notice.
They're going to
decide whether or not
to use your thing not because
of how quickly it loads,
because that would be a
fraction of a second, probably.
But it'd be all that
other stuff afterwards.
It says, what do
they care about?
What do they actually notice?
What do they perceive?
That's the thing to target.
And, of course, on the developer
side, this is the idle stuff.
There's that kind of--
what can we actually
give to the user
to make them feel
like they're getting the right
response in the right time?
But it may be that there's a bit
of sleight of hand on our part,
for sure.
JAKE: Hm.
[MUSIC PLAYING]